hello everyone how's everybody today
first of all I want to make sure that if
you can't hear me or if for some reason
you know my image goes out of whack I've
had problems in the past and that you
notified me in the comment section as
soon as you possibly can
I've got a little hearing aid in case
I'm gonna be checking on every now and
then to make sure that my sound doesn't
go out of whack okay and otherwise just
put a comment please the other thing I
want to mention is that next this coming
Wednesday now gonna have a lecture and
the reason for that I'm gonna be on jf
G's show again if everything goes
according to you know God's plan you
know doesn't always work that way
doesn't always turn out the way one once
but apparently I'm gonna be there it's
gonna be at 7 o'clock Eastern Standard
Time Philadelphia time just in case and
so instead of the lecture that I usually
have you can tune in a little later and
a few hours later in fact and you know
see what's going on at GFT show his show
by the way here I have it it's known as
the public space ok and you can find
Jean Francois I think God yep he is the
way you pronounce his name okay
everybody knows him as jfg because much
easier to pronounce you know his acronym
okay so what am I gonna be doing today
well today I'm gonna be doing a little
bit I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about fields okay talk about fields
and Fields is a very interesting subject
and it's very similar in many ways to
what I discussed in the last
presentation last lecture where I
analyzed mr. or the Jeff Yi and he
proposed spherical waves and they're all
kind of all the same you know some card
space-time some called ether spherical
waves of what of ether fields of what
well we'll find out today we'll find out
what these fields are and how they
relate to quantum ok ok so let me put
the topics here I'll put it up front so
that you know what I'm gonna be
discussing today there we go
I'll be discussing quantum particles
saying that they're not particles
quantum particles are alleged to be
excited fields they're very exciting and
so I'm gonna make a case for that I'm
gonna show that that's what quantum
people believe in fields are regions of
values that's essentially the definition
that's what it comes down to in other
words we're talking about a bunch of
numbers
they're mathematical abstractions this
implies that particles are vibrations of
numbers ok but you have numbers
vibrating regions of values that are
somehow excited and therefore quantum
particles do not qualify as objects for
the purposes of physics and if that's
the case then the matter of the universe
cannot be made of fields no one can make
that claim and so you might ask at this
point you know who makes such claims the
diamonds and this is just one of my
crazy things where I say oh look you
know this is what quantum says no I'm
gonna I'm gonna put mr. Sean Carroll and
he's a boy
fine Emir we're gonna let him speak for
himself so that I don't put words in his
mouth okay and here he is uh mr. Schine
peril himself okay
and he's a mathematical physicist in
other words he's not a physicist
mr. material is an AB stressed okay
what are what's an absolute rest is well
I've always told you you know AB
stresses are people who move
abstractions around they don't do
physical they do abstract and abstracts
the opposite of physical so if they're
doing abstractions they're not doing
physics just that simple and you know
they what would an abstraction is in
this case in this context is we're
referring to concepts okay and mr. Cairo
he transfers energy and other spirits
okay that's what he does for a living
and he talks about it in several places
okay and you know as a result of that he
was invited to give a presentation at
the Royal Institution he published a
book few years ago titled the particle
at the end of the universe he gave a
talk on the subject at the Royal
Institution in London and you can find
his talk at you know on YouTube okay
it's got the same title and you know mr.
Carroll has become one of the
popularizers of not only quantum
mechanics but of mathematical physics in
general together with a whole bunch of
other people we have mr. Carl Sagan you
know everybody knows Carl Sagan he's no
longer around but he was a famous
popularizer we have Michio Kaku Brian
Greene Brian Cox a British guy Neil
Tyson not to be confused with Mike Tyson
and Bill Nighy okay all these people are
popularizers and mr. Carroll now joins
us host of celebrities making money by
popularizing physics and you know so
keep an eye on him he's a
I see star he's a celebrity you know
he's got a color celebrity career to
look forward to okay now the part that
caught my attention you know his
presentation is the nature of particles
he started talking about what is a
particle specifically a quantum particle
and when you get into the issue of
particles and objects oh I really want
to hear it I I want to hear what your
version is okay because that's where the
problem with mathematical physics is in
the fact that they don't use objects in
fact they do everything but abstractions
with concepts okay and so physics is is
first and foremost the study of objects
you need an object you can't do physics
without an object and you would think
this is you know second nature to a
physicist and it's the other way around
in ten thousand years no one figured
that out that you do need an object to
do physics and as proof I mean if you
want proof okay I'll give you proof
here's your proof okay like you know
prosecutor discusses his case in court
here's proof proof is that you won't
find a single textbook of physics on
planet earth in the entire history of
man okay where first that they define
the word object and more important than
that that they tell you how important it
is to define the word object
specifically for the purposes of physics
and there you have it I mean I challenge
you don't take my word for it go out
there and get yourself a textbook of
physics and see if it starts because
that should be the further the starting
point take an elementary textbook of
physics you know something from in high
school whatever and look it up and find
out or at the library right and see see
if if they begin by defining what an
object is or even stating at some point
that objects are crucial in physics that
you can't do physics without an object
and you won't find this and this is
totally surprising for me because you
would think that a physicists guy who
calls himself a physicist not a
mathematical physicist but a true
genuine authentic physicist first thing
he should say is you know that you know
what do we do what do we do physics with
well we do physics with objects we have
to have objects and if that's the case
you got to define the term what is an
object for the purposes of physics okay
so you know you can't you can't do
physics without an object and that's the
problem that we have here with us
individual mr. Carroll who again he's an
abstruse he doesn't use objects he
doesn't understand what an object is and
so he can't be a physicist he's an
abstruse no doubt about it okay so you
know in physics I've got it here unknown
so that I mention it you know you can't
push or pull love you can't push or pull
grace or any other concept and likewise
because of that you know like you know
people say well I don't need for you to
tell me that of course you can't push or
pull love at least most people will
agree whether some people may not but
then they don't seem to realize that
when you push or pull other things which
people think are things you know you
know for example here here I have one
you know the black hole famous black
hole you know what is the black hole
made out of it's made out of pure mass
it crushes all matter out of existence
and yet the mathematicians will tell you
that this mass just a mass because there
is no matter in there this mass that and
this matter that has been completely
crushed out of existence leave something
behind called mass
and this mass now pulls on the star very
far away okay and pulls its gases out or
makes it revolve around itself how did
it do it what's the mechanism well you
know mathematician will only describe
and they'll say math mass affects a star
but you can't say that that's not a
physical mechanism you can't say that
mass does this or mass does that and
that's that's where these people go
wrong they're moving concepts or they're
using concepts as objects and you know
you've got the other one the famous
energy transfer here's energy for you
you see I've shown you this in the past
they say you can transfer energy well
there you have energy that's that's if
you look it up on the internet what
you'll find you'll find some kind of
smoke out there and they say that's
energy whatever that is to you okay so
this this is what these people are
saying they transfer and they don't know
to this day what energy is so you know
in fact I like to put this one up there
you know I say energy is really a ghost
that's what it is it's that that thing
that no one can define if they're your
thing right mysterious thing and
everybody uses the word they transfer it
they you know they kick it around they
transform it into mass and nobody knows
what they're doing nobody knows what
they're you know converting from one to
the other okay but yeah if if if on the
other hand we're talking about particles
well yeah that's that's a physical
object a particle is a physical object
if we're all referring to the same thing
you know here here I have a few
particles where is it
how's that are those objects oh yeah
those are objects we're assuming that
you know it's some kind of flow of
little beads or little rocks or whatever
you want to think of them as those are
objects sure they qualify as objects
okay there's no question that you can
move particles
particles qualify as objects for the
purposes of physics you know you have a
vacuum cleaner scoop up dust particles
right those are real particles and you
know here I show that you can also smoke
cigarette and blows these particles
known as smoke right and those are made
out of particles so we have no problem
there unless of course you know we're
talking about something else the two
particles I showed just now you know the
flow of little beads the smoke that all
qualifies as particles once you pick up
with your vacuum cleaner all that
qualifies as particles is that what mr.
Carroll is talking about is that what
he's referring to I don't think so so
let's see let's get on with this mr.
Carroll does the following he he begins
his lecture okay and he's trying to
define he's trying to make the case that
quantum has particles but those
particles that are not really particles
as what I just showed a minute ago those
particles are actually feels something
he calls fields and so he's gonna go
over this subject the subject of fields
so you get a pay attention to find out
you know what you know so you understand
what he's talking about really okay and
this is what he says he starts out like
this he says Newton thought of particles
like most people do as corpuscles right
[Music]
he says he that Newton was puzzled by
action at a distance the earth exerts a
force on the moon okay and and just like
the Sun exerts on the on the earth there
and this was Newton's dilemma just in
case you know the Sun throwing corpuses
the earth the earth throwing corpuscles
at the Sun you know how does this
mechanism
produce attraction from a distance and
so Newton said said you know this is
what happens with earth to the moon this
is the way he thought about it he
thought about it as particles going from
the earth to the moon or or from the
moon to the earth
anyway you any which either way that you
think about him
and and this is what Sean Carroll quotes
he says Isaac Newton was puzzled by
action at a distance the earth exerts a
force on the moon they're not touching
each other the earth seems to push out
across empty space to exert this fourth
this force Newton said that this
phenomenon of action at a distance made
no sense even though it was part of his
theory and of course how is it gonna
make sense if if Newton cannot imagine a
mechanism in which throwing particles at
the moon or vice versa the moon at the
earth how does he produce attraction
with that that's the mystery that we
have in front of us you can't do it with
particles and yes Newton was a particle
man okay and so you know Sean Carroll
done uses that as an analogy for the
problems quantum has as well you know
because they have the same thing that
they cannot make sense of it and Carroll
says the following he says he says to
Newton the action at a distant aspect of
his extremely successful theory of
gravitation was much like contemporary
physicists think about quantum mechanics
an incredibly successful manam analogy a
set of rules that fits the data to
wonderful precision like a precision had
anything to do with it right and yet
deep down in our bones we think it makes
no sense we can't quite make sense of it
look what he's saying he says we can't
make sense of it and again how can he
hit make sense of it if he's trying to
pull particles with by throwing stones
at him the only force that quantum
mechanics cannot explain is the force of
pull okay
there's no way that ever these people
are ever going to explain the force of
coal and and so whether it's Newton's
gravity or whether it's quantum
mechanics nowhere are you ever going to
be able to explain the force of coal by
throwing stones from particle to
particle or from earth to the moon
and that's the entire mystery okay and
so you know when quantum deals with
these discrete particles they can't
explain pool and of course it makes no
sense and they'll never be able to make
any sense of it because making sense
means that you're gonna give a physical
interpretation for what you observed in
the lab you smash particles you do
whatever you do they're fine now explain
it how do you explain it well you got to
give a physical interpretation that's
what mathematical physics cannot do and
that's what mr. taro cannot do and
mystery again the big mystery okay is
that you cannot produce pool with
particles so we're missing there's only
two forces in the universe you need two
forms of contact we can imagine you
either push or you pull there is no
other form of contact right where there
is motion forces using Newton's second
law you know force mass times
acceleration there's only two forces we
can imagine that's pushing you pull and
either of those can be you know you can
apply Newton's equations to those two
forms of to those two forces those two
types of forces okay but you can't do
that with particles you can push with
particles but you can't pull and so your
so quantum mechanics is missing half the
forces in the universe think about that
Missy half of the forces in the universe
yeah I said make you stop and think okay
so
had troubles you know he could figure
out how to do gravity with particles he
was a particle man he proposed also the
ether he everybody knows they believed
in the ether and ether was this sea of
particles invisible particles that's
what space was or what was contained
within space either way they thought of
them as gazillions of particles light
went through there some believed it was
the movement of the ether that was his
light that some people still believe
that and Newton believed that light was
some other particle that went through
the ether he thought about it as
something separate from the ether but
again you know what was light well he
thought of it as particles okay no
problem
that part he could imagine you know like
going out because electromagnetism is
some kind of push force right but then
gravity he was stuck there
he couldn't get past that point because
since okay so if we have particles what
is the mediator of gravity and he was
thinking again particles they said no I
can't explain it with particles of
course you can and quantum has the same
problem you know they they can't pull
with particles particles pulling on
particles they can I mean you have the
gluon right we discussed that a couple
weeks ago gluon is the force carrier
strong force they they claim that keeps
the course together now how do you keep
course together throwing stones at each
other so they cheat and what they do is
they put a bed spring in there if you
look at wherever you look up gluons
holding quarks together the pictures
that you will see officially and extra
efficiently all of them they show these
quarks screws these bedsprings holding
the quarks together they vibrate they do
all this stuff but it's always a
corkscrew so people get the wrong idea
that these particles are held together
because they have an elongated spring
there but that spring is supposed to be
a coil it's supposed to be the
trajectory of a particle
the gluon and if you have this thing
going around you can't explain Tugg and
what they do is they explain it with an
elastic or something similar to some
kind of elastic meant mechanism
including a bed spring if you try to
pull them with two corks you know
separate them farther and farther away
from each other you need more and more
strength
we all understand it we all understand
that but you got to put a bed spring to
do that or an elastic band or a bubble
gum or a rubber band or something that
stretches then you can understand it you
need an elongated connector the two
particles have to be physically
connected to you for you to apply that
analogy and this is the problem the
problem is that that's not what quantum
says quadrille doesn't deal with elastic
bands doesn't deal with rubber bands
with bubblegum with bed springs quantum
says particles and a particle you know
it is supposed to go outwards so the
analogy doesn't follow and so that now
just forced fitted in there it doesn't
belong in there but they they try to get
away with it
okay so Sean Carroll continues then he
says okay so quantum was in Newton
couldn't figure it out let's see if
someone else did and he says yeah
someone did and his name was Laplace
French guy okay and Laplace uh Sean
Carroll says the following for Laplace's
Laplace came up with a new theory of
gravity that gets rid of action at a
distance oh my god that's great that's
well that's all we want it to do okay we
wanted to figure this out is that when
applause says is that instead of
thinking about random forces between
objects very very far away imagine
there's a field filling the universe so
there we have your field okay and what
that means mathematically is that
Freeman listen to this okay this is the
important part what that means
mathematically needs to tell you what
this field is is that at every point in
space there's a number of value of the
field just like the temperature of the
air in this room and every point there
is a value the temperature at that point
of the air okay so there you have what a
field is we have a field and that's a
bunch of numbers a bunch of values
that's all I feel is just values okay
numbers magnitudes and and so according
to mr. Carrol he says that Laplace
figured out the problem
he solved the problem by saying oh we
have the concept of field I don't think
he called it a field at the know he did
in fact the field comes from Faraday
which comes some time later but Laplace
thought in terms of this field of
something extending throughout the
universe okay and mr. Carroll says that
this notion that mr. Laplace came up
with is the notion that they have a
field in other words values at each
point in space as you can see the way I
Illustrated this is the big numbers are
in the center and as you get farther and
farther away from the center of
something the force gets weaker whether
you're talking about electric or
magnetic or whether you're talking about
gravitational force it it gets weaker
the farther away you get from the
particle or the you know the thing in
the center whatever that is and how far
there's the field reach according to
mathematical physics it reaches to the
very edge of the universe of space-time
okay so just in case you're wondering
you know this field does cover the
entire universe but it turns out that
every particle has a field and all these
particles all these particles or all
these fields are superimposed one upon
the other so you try to figure out you
know how complex mother
run sir you know how complex mother
nature universe is they're saying all
these fields every particle in the
universe has a field the muon has a
field the pion has a field a neutrino
has a field an electron has a feel all
these have few protons every course
every every particle you can think of
that you can imagine has a field and
that's not counting you know the
gravitational field like from you know
the the earth or whatever so so we've
got all these fields all over the place
and it makes you stop and think what a
complex world the mathematicians have
created you know they we're in a world
in which these people say that every
particle has a field all these fields
are superimposed upon each other this is
how they this is how the physical
interpretation they're keeping for how
the universe runs now does this make
sense to you does it to me but you know
you have all kinds of people out there
ok so uh mr. Carroll continues he
clarifies he he gives us the notion of
Laplace's field ok and he says the
following he says there isn't anything
acting instantaneously and spooky at a
distance the gravitational potential is
very low here near the earth and it
climbs upwards as you go to the moon and
that changes and that change keeps going
forever
again if forever means that it reaches
all the way to the edge of the universe
if the universe has an edge ok so the
earth is affecting something that
stretches throughout the entire universe
the gravitational potential field there
is nothing acting across a very large
distance well there's a bit of a
contradiction there you know because
under one hand he's saying that that
there is then a field and then he
qualifies it as nothing he says there's
nothing acting across a very large
distance well what is this field thing I
thought the field extends throughout
long distances and all the way into the
ends of the universe is that nothing so
so so we got a cut he's got a
contradiction in the way he's presenting
this he's saying on the one hand you
know you have fields each field extends
to the edge of the universe and he's
trying to show that there is no action
at a distance so what is this field
thing I thought the field was put in
there or that's what was being proposed
to mediate action at a distance and
again he's saying that Laplace and also
I guess quantum mechanics and general
relativity are saying look there is no
action at a distance but there's a field
that extends all the way to the edge of
the universe and how does the feel to it
and again what they're trying to tell
you here is that they're gonna do it
mathematically don't you saying that
there are values their magnitudes your
numbers
stretching from one atom up from an atom
or whatever particle all the way to the
edge of the universe
so all they can do is have values all
along this this this region and all they
can do is measure and say about the
value of the field it could be magnetic
field it could be a gravitational field
the value of the field over here is
such-and-such
but that doesn't tell me what the
mechanism is how does that field effect
this thing that is so far away it's the
issue I just pointed out with with the
black hole the black hole has mass okay
and they say it's got so much mass
runaway mass that it can affect a star
far away fine that's a description you
can say look if you get close to the
black hole you're gonna feel more mass
you're gonna feel more gravity if you
get farther away you get less gravity
okay fine what's the mechanism and
that's what they're skipping there
they're never gonna tell you the
mechanism because a mathematician only
does numbers he does equations he does
values he does fields
he can't tell you a mechanism he can't
tell you how the magician did the trick
he only tells you what the magician did
on stage that's that's the issue okay so
uh he goes on he clarifies a little more
what a field is that's mr. Cara here he
says that's what we do these days we
talk about particles and about fields in
one sense the particle in the field are
the opposite of each other time a
particle is something that has one
location here's a particle it's nowhere
else any field is the opposite of that a
field is everywhere at every point in
space there's a value of the field again
he clarifies that a field it's just a
bunch of numbers and a particle is just
going to be an excitation of vibration
of those numbers because that's what
they're saying a particle is a particle
is the excitation of a field and then he
tells you that a fields is just a bunch
of values so we're introducing physics
in the context of mathematics
okay we're saying on the one hand that a
particle is a field of vibration about
field and a field is just a bunch of
numbers so so we're mixing physics with
mathematics here and they don't jive and
they don't match because if a field is a
bunch of numbers you can't say well a
particle is the vibration of the field
you can't use that terminology because
now you're talking about physic you're
talking about a physical object you're
saying this physical object is really in
vibration of numbers and the issue
really is that they don't have particles
in quantum mechanics what they're trying
to say to you is that they don't deal
with objects there is no such thing as a
particle what they call particle is just
a concentration of values it's where the
field becomes stronger the numbers are
greater that's all it is
and when you get farther away from the
center of the so-called particle
whatever a particle is then the values
get weaker that's all they're saying
it's like climbing a mountain coming
down the mountain the valley right when
you're at the top of the mountain at the
peak
that's the particle and when you come
down the mountain well you know you're
you're getting away we don't know where
the particle is chopped off because
values continue eternally okay
and so the question is you know where
does the particle begin with what's the
perimeter of the particle where does it
begin where does it end well it ends up
the peak I guess no problem there but
where does it begin if we're starting at
the at the base of the mountain where
does it begin because it continues
forever and so yeah you know they're
they're using physics in the context of
math and it doesn't really match there's
no correlation physics you can say look
this is a rock but you cannot say rock
is a vibration of a bunch of numbers
vibration of a field that the field is a
bunch of numbers and Iraq is just a
vibration of those numbers of those
values that's where the irrationality
comes into mathematical physics and they
live with this and they say oh we
understand it now they don't what they
do is they describe it they cannot
explain it in that sense there is no
understanding okay so let let let them
not fool you okay okay but he says you
know he reinforces his idea that there
are really no particles in fact he says
there are no ways I mean they've been
telling us since 1927 that what are
quantum particles especially the photon
and the electron those two really and
they say well you know a a photon is
both a pucking wave and a particle and
electrons in there like a part of going
away both you know sometimes it behaves
this way sometimes it behaves that way
which what they're really saying is that
here we simulate it using the particle
here we simulate our experiment using
the way so they're saying the same thing
they're saying it is a wave and it is a
particle
it's not only that it behaves it is
because that's what they're using to
simulate I mean if I say you know I'm
gonna simulate how the window broke and
I bring a rock I say look this is how
the window broke with a rock then you
can understand because you're using a
rock okay
and that's different than saying look
I'm gonna simulate it with a crowbar
so crowbars Ella gated Rock is like you
know concentrated kind of particle big
particle so they're kind of different
ones that elongated object the other
ones a you know concentrated thing like
so so we got something different whether
we simulate with a wave or whether we
simulate with a particle or corpus or B
and so what what Carol says is the
following he says is like for example a
particle or a wave a wave is sort of a
vibration in the field again he's that
hasn't said absolutely anything there
because I feel as a bunch of numbers so
what is more important is it the
particle aspect of reality or is it the
field aspect of reality
well we don't care what's important we
want to know what his theory is and
again we're not interested here in
knowing exactly what Mother Nature has
out there what we want to do is
understand mr. Carroll's proposal that's
what we're trying to understand so we
don't care about what is real out there
at this point we just care about
understanding his theory he's kind of
giving us a theory and he says look it's
light a particle or a wave he says well
we don't think any of those are
important what would what's important is
that it's fields fields are important
okay that's the answer
it's not a mystery they always tell you
that that that question you know they
never tell you the answer I went decades
of my lives you know so what's the
answer to this he said he went decades
of his life you know trying to figure
out what they were saying and and he
still doesn't understand what they were
saved for sure
so what's the answer to this this is the
answer it's fields the reason why the
Higgs boson is a concept that is hard to
grasp it's cause you need to stop
thinking of the world in terms of
particles you need to start thinking
about the world in terms of fields okay
so now we we got a little bit of a
problem because since 1927 they talked
about quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics is a particle theory quantum
means particle that's what quantum means
it means a you know a bunch of something
and and so what they were saying is that
you know everything is concentrated in
this little particle since they can't
explain absolutely anything with that
with that proposal in the last maybe 20
30 40 years a little more maybe they've
come up with what's called quantum field
theory okay quantum field theory is
something else they're saying look what
we see what we see they're really or
what we detect is a particle but if we
had the eyes of God we would see that
the mountain extends all the way to the
Valiants it's a field that extends all
the way to the edge of the universe and
so that's the field here now they've
changed the so called particle and they
say look it's not really a particle like
we've always told you it's a field and a
field extends forever well that's not a
particle it's not even a wave so you
know they're saying the wave is the
waving of the field we're back to waves
wave is the wave another field in some
Whitefield the field is a bunch of
numbers bunch of values and that's
what's wavy so again they can't get any
physique Audi to what they're saying
they'll never do be able to do that
because they're using the wrong language
they're using the wrong they're
proposing the wrong simulators they're
using the wrong objects to simulate what
they see in the lab or what they see you
know in your experiments and this this
is where the problem is okay so he
continues one more time here you said
as uh because people will ask you know
our tables aren't everything made out of
particles that's what we've been told
for so many years and he says and you
say to yourself well but things like
this table are made of atoms and atoms
have electrons and so forth in them and
the electrons are particle right there
are particles in the world and he says
no there aren't
there's the state that's the secret that
we physicists have never told you but
Here I am I'm gonna tell you right now
oh I can't wait mr. Carroll is gonna
break the field wide open okay and he
says the following he says the reason
you are allowed to think of particles is
because of quantum mechanics the world
is made of fields but quantum mechanics
says that when you look at the world you
don't see it directly
now we're talking about observer about
seeing of course you can't see a field
you know I mean there's there's nothing
out of me get that a little bigger here
yeah you know there's a Meccano field
and for sure they can't see the
particles that they're dealing with so
they can't see either one they can't see
the fields or the particles okay so so
the issue here is that you know he's
introducing now an observer okay he's
saying it's an observer issue he says
when you look you don't see it directly
according to quantum mechanics the
reason you think that there are
particles as that there are actually all
these fields filling empty space and at
every point in space there's dozens of
little vibrating fields in front of you
but quantum mechanics say that when you
look at the field close enough they
resolve into individual particles so
essentially what mr. Carroll is saying
that this is an issue of of
magnification of what the magnification
you choose to use on your scanning
electron microscope or atomic force
microscope if you have God's eyes and
you can really focus all the way well
you would see particles but as you pull
out you see the field extending or maybe
it's the other way around maybe you know
when you look at it from far away it
looks like a particle
but as you get very close you see the
this net this web which extends all the
way to the edge of the universe so fine
even even if we concede that what's the
mechanism how do how do we produce
attraction with the famous field this
this is the see they're not answering
the question the question is how does a
magnet pull on another magnet that's
what I want to know and it turns out
that you know in that presentation that
Carol gave he laughs at the insane clown
posse saying while these guys said
freaking magnets how do they work and he
says of course we know how're they
worked now they know they can't Carol
cannot explain how a magnet attracts
another from a distance he cannot
explain the mechanism he can describe
and say look the field gets weaker and
the farther away one magnet is from the
other and he gets stronger when you put
the magnets together he can tell me that
he can tell me how much strength the
magnets have he cannot tell me the
mechanism now one person graduated with
a PhD in the last 100 years at any
university on the planet can tell you
how a magnet physically attracts another
magnet by what mechanism in fact how a
magnet attracts a pin okay like you
throw iron filings on the table you put
a magnet and a magnet scoop some up from
a distance how does it do that magic how
does it pull on these particles with
with particles you can't do a particles
you can't do waves if you throw waves at
them now they say fields quantum field
theory okay fields let's let's do it
with fields the field extends all the
way to the edge of the universe what's
the mechanism how does the field now
physically pull on the iron finally
that's what I want to know and you know
for them to say look the far door where
you get the weaker it is the closer you
are the stronger it is well that's a
description some mathematical
description they can't even put values
there and that's I can install
my problem the problem here is mechanism
causes we want to we want to have and a
physical interpretation for the
mechanism someone asks you how does a
car run you say well the gas goes from
here goes to the you know to the Pistons
the Pistons move the wheels and the car
moves forward fine that's how you
explain it that's the type of
explanation we want for how a magnet
attracts another in other words the
Insane Clown Posse is really cated here
freakin magnets how do they work
please tell us and we're not saying how
description we're seeing how explanation
tell us the mechanism of how it works
now that the scripts are saying it does
yeah we know it does and we know we can
measure and we can put values if we want
to know the mechanism and it turns out
that there's a lady who did an article
on careless presentation and she does in
fact use that as an example said when
you hold two magnets too close together
you can feel their attraction or
repulsion before they even touch yeah an
interaction between two magnetic fields
okay so and she's from what is it
Fermilab slack the Stanford Linear
Accelerator okay so interaction between
two magnetic fields okay so what is a
field you know or what does it look like
and here you have what a field looks
like these are the different kinds of
fields
okay in the religion of mathematics a
field is a quantity as mr. Carol just
told us that has a value for each point
in space and time and here you have
different field you have the electric
fields famous you've seen them probably
in the high school physics book so
called physics magnetic field
gravitational field okay so we have all
these fields of those lines there that
you see with little arrows those are
vectors
and they get weaker in other words the
vector has magnitude and direction and
here they show that like in the
gravitational field is an example here
you see the the vectors are pointing
towards the earth in other words the
strength of the vector or the value of
the vector you know gets stronger as you
get closer to the center of the earth
and you can even put that arrow in the
opposite direction and just say it gets
weaker as you get farther away from the
earth okay that's a description so far
we have no idea how the earth attracts
the moon or how the Sun attracts the
earth and so when this lady says that
you know it's the interaction between
two magnetic fields well there you have
the magnetic field in the in the center
let me make it bigger so that so that we
can see it better okay
and on the bottom I remove the magnet so
it doesn't interfere with our line of
sight so we have the magnetic field
alone that's the one we should use
because we're talking about fields are
not about magnets here and there saying
this is the mechanism and we want to see
this mechanism okay
so there it is there's the magnetic
field okay all those are vectors and you
can see which way the pointing they're
coming in from the South Pole which is
on the left side and going out the North
Pole of the magnet on the right hand
side we have this without gotten rid of
the magnet was interfering with our line
of sight with our yeah it was
distracting us and now we have a
magnetic field okay so we have to and
then it feels like this how do they
produce attraction so for her for this
they jettison to say that it's an
interaction between two magnetic videos
magnetic fields what's the mechanism
show me how these two fields which are
just a bunch of numbers interact
interact as a world of physics not a
word of mathematics she's gonna use the
word interaction we're talking about
physics she can't bring in the word
feels she cannot say two magnetic fields
interact because as we all just heard
feel is a number bunch of numbers that's
all yeah bunch of numbers don't interact
unless they want to be fine interact in
some weird way that well then again like
I said at the beginning mr. Carroll is
not a physicist he's an ass the cyst
okay so here I'll leave you with this
that's the field yeah that's what a
particle is a vibration of a field
according to quantum mechanics and until
we get some kind of physical object
that's what a few will always be that's
what a particle is and that's what these
people are talking about so I don't know
your judge you know what a field is now
it just has to do with mathematics
nothing at all to do with physics and
this is what we we have to really pay
attention that these people are no
longer than physics they have been doing
physics in a hundred years or probably
even more what they've been doing is
mathematics mathematics is the religion
of mathematical physics
I caught mathematics because they do
everything with magic why because they
move concepts they new abstractions
there are physicists there extra sis
okay okay one more time just in case you
missed the introduction on Wednesday I'm
gonna be a GF G's program here here's
again one more time
and
nobody's the public space and if
everything goes right car doesn't step
over me run by a relativist by the way
that's what you have and uh-oh voice
rattle oh my god let's see what out a
minute wonder why this happens
can you hear me
yeah I I think it just dies for some
reason I I have no idea why it does this
it's like after 50 minutes that's when
it occurs sometimes it occurs before but
in general I noticed that it takes a
while and then it that happens I have no
idea what it's doing I checked the wires
I have no idea what else to check I
don't know why it does that
anyways finishing up here I was saying
that on Wednesday I'll be on jf cheese
program here it is it's known as the
public space and it's gonna be at 1900
hours seven o'clock in the evening
Philadelphia time Eastern Standard Time
okay that's Quebec time that's where jfg
is at and so I will not be holding a
lecture on Wednesday because of this I
urge you to tune in I'm gonna be
discussing the Rope model and so if
you're interested well then you'll hear
a little bit about it okay and I'm so
sorry that this happens I don't know
what else to do if someone has any idea
what what else to check I'll be glad to
hear it because I tried everything I've
tried the cables camera I have no idea
anyways we'll see you on Wednesday if
you tuned in to jf geez the public space
podcast we'll see you then
bye bye